What if our universe comes with a self destruct button to eliminate itself so
cleanly and efficiently that every single physical thing would just stop
existing and life would be impossible forever.
The ultima to ecological catastrophe vacuum decay.
Yeah.
To explain how our universe could destroy itself,
we need to understand two principles,
one energy levels.
A core idea in physics is that everything has an energy level.
The higher the level,
the more energy is and the system would,
for example,
has a high level,
it can be burned.
A process that releases the chemical energy stored in its molecular bonds and
turns it into heat.
The ash leftover is at a lower energy level than the wood before to stupidity.
Everything in our universe tries to move towards its ground state in which it's
completely stable and has as little energy as possible.
For example,
a ball on the hill is unstable and has a lot of potential energy.
When listervs it will roll down into the valley and lose its potential energy in
the process.
The ball is now in its ground state unstable.
It will remain like that.
Everything in our universe follows these two principles.
If something has a lot of energy,
it's unstable.
It was to get rid of it to become stable and reach its ground state.
This is true for every system,
even in the weird world of quantum mechanics.
If our current understanding of physics is correct than the universe gets its
properties from quantum fields,
we explained them in detail in another video for this video.
Imagine them as the rules of the universe.
They tell particles how to behave and interact
like everything in the universe.
They want to be in the lowest energy level possible,
which is called a vacuum state.
This has nothing to do with vacuum in space.
It's just called this way because scientists are bad at naming things
within called the fields reach to their vacuum state except maybe one.
It's possible that the Higgs field is not stable,
but Matt has stable,
which is a fancy way of saying that it pretends to be stable,
but rarely is not great.
It would be a false vacuum.
The Hicksville is responsible for giving particles.
They're mass,
which rules,
how almost everything in the universe interacts.
What would happen if the Higgs field isn't a false vacuum?
Think of our ball in the valley.
The ball is the Higgs field.
The value might not be the lowest energy state for the Higgs field.
There might be an even deeper value that it wants to get to.
This would mean that the Higgs field has a lot of potential energy waiting to be
released.
The Higgs field could be like a piece of wood but drenched in gasoline waiting
to set the universe fire.
The random spark like quantum tunneling could release the potential energy of
the Higgs field.
This could happen at any time and without warning.
If at any point in space,
this so called a vacuum decay starts.
There is no turning back.
As the Higgs field crashes into the lower energy states,
it releases a massive amount of potential energy.
This energy pushes the space around it over the barrier which releases more
potential energy as fear of the new stable Hicksville door.
True vacuum grows at the speed of light in all directions.
Imagine it like setting a sea of gasoline,
the size of the universe on fire.
This fear is surrounded by Shell of energy that devours everything that comes
into contact with whatever it touches is eliminated from existence.
The bubble will continue to grow forever deleting the universe on its way.
There is no way to be warned since it's so fast,
but there's nothing we could do anyway.
Now,
destruction would be instant in a fraction of a second earth would be gone,
but it actually gets worse
as the energy level of the Hicksville changes.
It changes all the physics and the true vacuum of the sphere.
The standard model will be overthrown,
superseded by different physics that we don't know how fundamental particles
behave,
how atoms hold together,
how chemicals react.
Vacuum decay weren't just destroy life.
It will destroy chemistry itself.
Making life as we know is impossible.
We simply have no idea what it will be like in site.
It might be a shadow of what it is now or not.
We don't know if vacuum decay happens.
The outlook is indeed grim if you feel slightly wide.
Now dubby at this point,
false fact,
Kim is speculation based on our current understanding of particle physics,
which might be wrong.
It's kind of like using a ruler to measure a continent
so you can do it,
but you might be off by quite a bit at the end.
Right now,
no one can say a vacuum decay is a thing that's real or just a scary idea.
But even if one or multiple spheres of death have already started expanding,
the university is so big that they might not reach us for billions of years.
If they're far enough away,
they might not ever be able to reach us because of the expansion of the
universe.
The speed of light is not that fast on the scale of the universe.
So while vacuum to Kate is fascinatingly scary right now,
there are other things we should be more afraid of.
In contrast to vacuum decay,
we have the power to prepare for most of them.
Videos like this one take hundreds of hours to make.
So supporters on page.
Sean,
if you like to learn more about the destruction of everything,
it really helps us out.
We tried to destroy the universe at least once every few months.
So let us know in the comments if you have doomsday scenarios you would like us
to cover.